well can you remember how long ago was
it was the last time you actually set
foot inside of a mall well we wanted to
look at how popular malls still are and
so we asked and according to our online
poll many of you opting for online
shopping or other methods in order to
just stay out of them all mary jane
belliesa takes a look at how malls are
keeping up with the changing times
from a hispanic marketplace to a barber
shop and even a new school it's just one
of the many new ways traditional malls
are evolving to bring in customers and
cater to the community's needs brian
walker with the retail association of
nevada says malls are more than just a
shopping center
i think what they're showing us that
they're successful at doing is providing
different parts of an experience to
really enhance your day you know you can
go to the fashion show mall and learn
now how to play table games um and
they've brought that experience to them
all and i think that's something unique
so what we've created is kind of our own
little ecosystem here timo casella the
general manager at the boulevard mall
agrees he says not only do they have
your conventional stores but commercial
services as well we added a lot of
experience related tenants like the
movie theaters
the seaquest aquarium and the rec center
family entertainment venue but also we
have
workplaces here we have office tenants
that bring about three thousand to four
thousand employees to the site every day
so that just brings customers to our
regular mall and shoppers are taking
notice of the changes referring to the
malls as a one-stop hub to shop eat and
be with family since i've been here
before years
here
in nevada and it's different it's
beautiful
i love it something interactive more
with the kids which kind of helps i
really like that malls are i don't think
they're going anywhere they're certainly
going to be a community destination
other malls are also taking a similar
approach both meadows mall and the
galleria offer an arcade and office
spaces with the fashion show offering
high-end retail on the strip reporting
from the boulevard mall mary jane valeza
live local now